Michael Cohen's testimony gives everyone
what they want Rashidah Talib goes off
the rails and president Trump's North
Korea gambit comes apart I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
we have a lot of breaking news on the
North Korea front we're gonna get to
that in just one second first let's talk
about hiring at your business hiring is
challenging but there's one place you
can go or hiring is simple fast and
smart it's a place where growing
businesses connect to qualified
candidates that place is zip recruiter
comm slash daily wire zip recruiter
sends your jobs to over 100 of the web's
leading job boards but they don't stop
there with their powerful matching
technology zip recruiter scans thousands
of resumes to find people with the right
experience and then invites them to
apply to your job as applications come
in zip recruiter analyzes each one and
they spot like the top candidates so you
never miss a great match zipper career
is so effective that 80% of employers
who post on zip recruiter get a quality
candidate through the site within the
very first day and right now my
listeners can try zip recruiter for free
at this exclusive web address zip
recruiter comm slash daily wire that zip
recruiter comm slash Dai ly WI re zip
recruit comm slash daily where there's a
reason we use zip recruiter here at the
daily wire offices whenever we are
looking to hire you should as well they
make it easy they make it quick and they
make it efficient zip recruiter is the
smartest way to hire check them out at
zip recruiter comm slash daily wear and
try them out for free alright so the
president's gambit in North Korea is an
utter giant shambolic failure it is just
it's it's a giant fail I have been very
critical of the president's strategy on
North Korea but I was willing to
withhold judgment my feeling was if the
president wants to try his sycophant see
for denuclearization a negotiation
tactic if he wants to pretend that he
can flatter kim jeong-hoon into giving
up his nuclear weapons which again makes
no sense the only reason Kim jong-un is
even a player on the world stage is
because of his nuclear weapons but if
Trump thinks that he can flatter him
into something if he thinks that he can
grant him world credibility by meeting
with him and conferring America's
imprimatur of quazy approval upon him if
he thinks he can get him to denuclearize
well it's a high-risk high-reward
strategy because if it works then the
president was the Nobel Peace Prize but
if it doesn't work then the United
States has just sunk down to the level
of the North Korean dictatorship
diplomatically by sitting in a room with
one of the worst people on planet earth
a man who is keeping millions of people
in a giant gulag a person who has
executed legitimately tens of thousands
of people a person who kills his
relatives with anti-aircraft guns and
anthrax at airports the president of the
States sat down with that guy not once
but twice and again if this was all part
of some grand plan fine it turns out
today it was not part of a grand plan
and I'm gonna show you how this whole
thing fell apart
how is never properly planned and how
the President of the United States made
the United States look foolish in this
entire endeavor and continues to do so
today in his talk about Kim jong-un the
bottom line is this negotiation takes
place between people who are seeking
some sort of common interest the United
States does not have a common interest
with the Kim regime now is it possible
that negotiators could find such a
common interest perhaps but that would
require actual diplomatic initiative
that would require pre negotiations that
would require that Kim jong-un had
already signed off on some stuff before
President Trump ever got in a room with
him what you don't do is send the
President of the United States around
like a used car salesman trying to pawn
off a bad lemon on some on some
unsuspecting schmuck and it's not what
the president of the United States is
there to do we have an entire diplomatic
core that is there to ensure that at the
end of the summit like this that
something gets signed that looks like a
concession by the North Koreans or that
looks like a deal or that looks like
anything the president didn't even get
an empty pledge from the North Koreans
this time he walked away from the table
now the president is right to walk away
from the table my point is he shouldn't
have been at the table in the first
place you don't come to the table with
the worst dictatorship on planet Earth
simply because you want a photo-op you
better have a plan because otherwise you
just took the most powerful most moral
country in the history of the world and
put it on an equal photo-op playing
field with one of the worst people on
planet earth here's how things went down
according to the New York Times today
President Trump and Kim Jong hoon North
Korea's leader abruptly ended their
second summit meeting on Thursday after
talks collapsed with the two leaders
failing to agree on any steps for
nuclear disarmament or measures to ease
tensions on the Korean Peninsula
sometimes you just have to walk mr.
Trump said at an afternoon news
conference in Hanoi the capital of
Vietnam that's true sometimes you do
just have to walk the question is why
you had walked into Vietnam in the first
place
without any sort of pre negotiations
again I bashed President Obama back when
he was Senator Obama in 2008 for saying
he wanted to be with the Iranians and
the Cubans without precondition you
think I'm not gonna do the same thing
with regard to North Korea and president
especially when the president confers
all sorts of beautiful words upon a
piece of human debris like kim
jeong-hoon the President of the United
States went to Vietnam and suggested
that kim jeong-hoon unlike you know many
spoiled billionaires kids he was really
a normal guy and then they issued a
statement yesterday the United States
issued a statement talking about
president Trump's special relationship
with Kim you don't have to hug the
dictator to negotiate with the dictator
you don't have to do that but here's the
problem the president has a personal
negotiation strategy he's been using it
in business for years and that strategy
is essentially blustering threats
followed by the possibility of a warm
cordial embrace the president thinks he
can flatter people into doing what he
wants and if he doesn't get that then he
tries to threaten them into doing what
he wants well that's not a strategy that
is just a wild vacillation from one
point to the other remember two years
ago the President of the United States
was threatening little Kim jong-un with
the biggest nuclear button in the world
and now he's calling him his best friend
does that seem like a strategy to you or
does that just seem like wild flailing
about I'll tell you after what I saw
today from the president it seems like
wild flailing about according to Trump
he said Kim had offered to dismantle the
North's most important nuclear facility
if the United States lifted the
sanctions on his nation but he would not
commit to do the same for other elements
of its weapons program mr. Trump said
that was a deal breaker
he said it was about the sanctions
basically they wanted the sanctions
lifted in their entirety but we couldn't
do that well that's something that you
should have known walking in is it not I
mean this is what again we have an
entire State Department that is designed
to do these things but I want you to see
how people moved from Trump is a genius
for engaging in the negotiation to Trump
is a genius from walking away in the
space of 48 hours it's wildly
inconsistent not only is it wildly
inconsistent again I point you to the
fact that Barack Obama did this people
on the right would lose their bleep they
would lose their minds and they should
because the President of the United
States represents not only the people
living in the United States today he
represents the Constitution of the
United States he represents the American
mission he represents liberty is one of
the most shameful things about the Obama
presidency the fact that President Obama
was constantly trying to make common
cause with the Iranian mullahs for
example it was gross well the same thing
is true
when the President of the United States
does this now again I think all of this
was true before he walked away the
reason I'm angry is not because he
walked away that's the right thing I'm
glad he walked away he should walk away
the United States is not in a position
to make concessions to an evil gulag
Master something straight out Austin
Powers over here were not in that
position so the president is correct to
walk away the question is I was assured
that there was a strategy here I was
assured that there was a broader
strategy here what is the broader
strategy is there no broader strategy I
was assured by the president that the
threat of a nuclear North Korea had
completely been taken off the table he
said that on Twitter that we shouldn't
worry about it any more
okay so what's the plan so what's the
plan was there ever a plan and people
for people who say well you know it's
just talking it's just talking you know
it's not just talking when the president
of the United States creates an image of
the United States as a place willing to
overlook the most brutal human rights
violations on the planet in exchange for
nothing in exchange for literally
nothing apparently there's a meeting
though scheduled today the premature
ends to the negotiations leaves the
unusual rapprochement between the United
States and North Korea that has unfolded
for most of a year at a deadlock with
the North retaining both its nuclear
arsenal and facilities believed to be
producing additional fissile material
for warheads it also represents a major
setback at a difficult political moment
for Trump who's long presented himself
as a tough negotiator capable of
bringing adversaries into a deal and had
made North Korea the signature
diplomatic initiative of his presidency
and here I will point out that the
president's history of negotiation as
president of the United States has been
rather poor it has been rather poor on
every budget deal he has caved to the
Democrats his undercut his own party to
do so in negotiations with North Korea
he comes away with nothing after
spending an enormous amount of his own
political capital and the political
capital of the United States on these
foolhardy negotiations now I'm gonna
show you how this unfolded so as of
yesterday president Trump was still
talking up all this stuff he said listen
we're having great meetings we had
dinner it was fabulous
we're sitting next to each other we're
best friends
and a special relationship that's a
phrase usually reserved for the United
States his relations with Great Britain
the special relationship between the
u.s. and Great Britain was the hallmark
of World War two now he's saying that he
has a very special relationship with a
guy who literally straps his uncle to an
anti-aircraft gun and blew him in half
who literally took his brother-in-law
and had him anthrax at a public airport
but we have a special relationship
now maybe you're so cynical about
politics or America's moral standing in
the world that you think it doesn't
matter what the president says after all
who really cares does it really make
much of a difference the answer is yes
it legitimizes Kim jong-un in his own
country it legitimizes kim jeong-hoon
around the world it makes it look like
kim jeong-hoon outplayed the President
of the United States that's what it
looks like right here and Kim jong-un
knew that knew what he was playing at he
said yesterday I have a feeling that
good results are gonna come from this
why because his real hope is that he was
gonna be able to sucker Trump into
removing the sanctions that's why again
the president is absolutely correct to
walk away from the negotiations the
question is why he was at the table in
the first place without any of these
things being discussed it's not like
this is a minor ancillary issue that
killed the deal this was the central
issue of the deal the central issue was
what is North Korea going to do in
exchange for removing sanctions and it
better be total denuclearization that
was the entire premise of these
negotiations and when we say that it's
what what I love is this is the
ridiculous line then it's some sort of
massive win for the United States to sit
down with a tin-pot dictator like Kim
Jong hoon really the president of the
United States can sit down with anyone
on earth that he wants when the most
prominent recent guests to North Korea
from America was Dennis Rodman I'm gonna
go with Kim jong-un social book is not
exactly full up it's not a big win for
the United States to sit down with a
piece of garbage like Kim jong-un okay
here was Kim jong-un saying that he had
a feeling that good results were gonna
come out of this
well it's too early to tell but I
wouldn't say that I'm from what I feel
right now I do have a feeling bad good
result with him oh okay so that is you
know again his good result was that he
thought he was gonna roll Trump now
Trump wasn't fully rolled good for him
but again if he had been full he rolled
I'm sure there would be people praising
him today for that too I'm gonna talk in
a second about how this thing ended how
it went down and how the defense went
from Trump is a brilliant negotiator to
Trump has has all the the cojones in the
world for walking away from this he has
cojones for walking in and he has
cojones from walking out well then you
have now created an untestable and
unverifiable thesis okay if the
hypothesis is that it's good for him to
walk in because something good will
result and then nothing good results so
it's good for him to walk out which was
it didn't get to that in just one second
and I'll explain really why I'm so
ticked this morning so I am I'm upset I
will explain in a second why I'm so tech
we'll get to that in just one second
first let's talk about your sleep
quality we're never going to agree on
everything but I think we can all agree
that we can use more sleep
getting a great night's sleep is easier
and more affordable than you think you
don't need a new expensive mattress or
sleeping pills you just need to change
your sheets that's why you should check
out bull and branch everything bull and
branch makes from bedding to blankets is
made from pure 100% organic cotton which
means they start out super soft they get
even softer over time bull and branch
sheets are so comfortable once my wife
and I had some we have legitimately
thrown out all the other sheets in our
house there's that good
it sort of ruins other sheets for you
you buy directly from them so you're
essentially paying wholesale prices
luxury sheets can cost up to a thousand
dollars in the store but when branch
sheets aren't only a couple of hundred
bucks everyone who tries Boleyn branch
sheets loves them that's why they have
thousands of five-star reviews and
Forbes The Wall Street Journal Fast
Company they're all talking about Boleyn
branch even three u.s. presidents sleep
on bull and branch sheets shipping is
free you can try them for 30 nights if
you don't love them send them back for a
refund but I doubt you're gonna want to
send them back there is no risk and no
reason not to give them a try to get you
started right now my listeners get 50
bucks off your first set of sheets at
bull and branch calm promo code Ben go
to bull and branch calm today for 50
bucks off your first set of sheets that
is bol L and branch calm promo code Ben
Bowlin brain
komm promo code ben go check them out
right now okay so president trump meets
with kim and everything is going
swimmingly everything is going just
great and republicans are saying well
it's going so great over there and
that's why democrats scheduled the
michael cohen hearing because it's just
terrible they wanted to distract from
president Trump over in Vietnam because
things are just going so awesome over
there and then you got Kim saying listen
I'm ready to denuclearize I'm prepared
to denuclearize now what he means by the
nuclear eyes obviously is that the
United States pulls out of its all of
its troops out of South Korea and the
entire continent becomes free of
American influence that's what Kim meant
by denuclearize so when he says this
understand that he is lying at least if
you think the nuclearized means he stops
his nuclear program but here was Kim
making the overture that is not real
[Music]
okay so you know she is that that would
be kim jeong-hoon and his sister
basically saying yeah this is what we're
discussing and they have no intention of
handing over their nuclear weapons the
minute the Kim family hands over the
nuclear weapons they get to posed in
North Korea everybody knows this this is
obvious to anyone who's watching this
but that doesn't stop president Trump's
fans from praising his brilliance in
negotiation early on in this thing and
as I say I was willing to withhold
judgment not moral judgment because
again the United States should not be
granting this sort of legitimacy to an
evil dictator I wasn't willing to
suspend judgment when it came to the
president flattering kim jong hoon to
the skies and talking about his
beautiful pen pal relationship with him
people saying today that it's just like
Ronald Reagan and Gorbachev two
differences one Gorbachev represents in
a nation that was an existential threat
to the United States and that ruled over
half of the Eastern Europe and also
President Reagan never downplayed the
evil of the evil empire he was
constantly talking about the evil of the
Soviet Union constantly president Trump
has taken the opposite tack which is to
sort of pretend that it's not all that
evil over there for purposes of trying
to flatter the Kim regime into doing
what he wants
okay so President Trump is doing these
negotiations and supposedly everything
is going swimmingly everything is going
great newt gingrich's obviously a major
fan of the president he goes on Fox News
and he says this is just it's fantastic
stuff looked at Kim jong-un he's opening
up to the world look at him he's just
opening up everybody watching tonight if
you see Kim jong-un answering questions
off-the-cuff to the news media you're
seeing a historic change that every
person in North Korea is going to pick
up on I mean it is an enormous moment
because he's he's coming out of a shell
of total control into a world where he's
now trying to interact with Trump in a
way that makes him more normal and I
think there's a there's a real piece of
this of trying to become normal
oh well that's what's happening here
he's becoming normal now I heard the
same exact bullcrap
about the Iranian regime when Barack
Obama was trying to hand over the store
to them
oh they're moderates now they're
normalizing that's what they're doing
they're becoming normal don't you see
well everybody's in the streets chanting
chanting death to America
okay so there's all this build-up oh the
brilliant negotiation tactic of going to
a place and being with a person in the
same place at the same time Wow and
saying nice things about that person
what what to diplomatic initiative what
incredible now as I said if the result
had been something of any substance or
if there'd been a plan then I would
concede this was out of the box
it was weird but it worked that's not
what happened and not only did the
president walk away from the table as he
should have because North Korea never
intended on giving anything up not only
that but then Trump did something and
this is what has really set me off this
today what has really set me off today
is president Trump was asked about otto
warmbier now you'll remember the case of
otto warmbier who's an American college
student he visited North Korea and he
took a poster off the wall supposedly
the North Korean regime took hold of him
and literally beat him to death they
beat him into a coma
they made him a vegetable and then they
shipped him back to the United States
you'll remember it was a major issue
because one Donald J Trump spoke about
otto warmbier and had his parents to the
State of the Union address just a couple
of the year a couple of years ago now
here's the President of the United
States the most moral power on the face
of the earth and in human history
talking about how he trusts kim
jeong-hoon that otto warmbier was not
actually murdered i don't warm BR
something bad happened to him but I mean
I trust this Kim guy over here the one
who murders his relatives with
anti-aircraft guns just wasn't to his
advantage to allow that to happen
those prisons are rough they're rough
places and bad things happened but I
really don't believe that he was he I
don't believe he knew about it did he
say did he tell you that he did not did
Kim Jong to tell you felt badly about it
speak to him he felt very badly but he
knew the case very well but he knew it
later you know you got a lot of people a
big country a lot of people and in those
prisons and those camps you have a lot
of people and some really bad things
happened to Otto some really really bad
thing why are you what he tells me he
tells me that he didn't know about it
and I will take him at his word okay
absolute sheer unmitigated moral garbage
right there I will take him at his word
how many American citizens does he think
North Korea was holding he was holding
an American citizen everybody knew about
it Kim Jong Un's certainly knew about it
this guy was beat to death beat to death
and now he's gonna take kim jeong-hoon
an evil piece of garbage at his word
that's what the presidents of the United
States and don't tell me the alternative
is nuclear war if the alternative were
nuclear war don't you think we would
have been at nuclear war with North
Korea sometime over the past 20 years
they've had nuclear weapons for a solid
15 years at this point I've been told
over and over this is the same exact
tactic you heard about Iran well if you
don't go for President Obama's deal that
means you want war with the Iranians no
it absolutely does not I am NOT
suggesting that war with the North
Koreans is the solution I am suggesting
that the solution is not the President
of the United States going out there and
saying that he trusts a man who had an
American murdered and and Trump does
this all the time he does this all the
time and I know there are a bunch of
people out there whose well that's real
politique you know you know I'm just I'm
so dark and cynical about politics this
house of cards there's no moral
component to politics you know some
Trump is praising Putin because it's
advantageous or if he's praising kim
jeong-hoon because it's advantageous
well what's the big deal I mean don't we
all know that politics is dirty pool and
people it's this oh it's the scene from
The Godfather where Michael Corleone is
walking around with Kay and he's
explaining how he's just like a senator
because senators have people killed too
there's kind of faux sophistication
about politics well you know we're
pretty bad too Trump has done that
routine with Vladimir Putin for years he
said that he took Vladimir Putin at his
word that he didn't interfere in the
2016 election he said that while
Vladimir Putin has had his political
opponents killed we here in the United
States have done some of that stuff too
and now he's extending that to North
Korea that there is no excuse for this
none there's not I mean imagine you're
the womb' your family and you're sitting
home and Trump brought you to the State
of the Union address two years ago not
ten years ago two years ago and made
your son a national issue and now he's
standing there saying well you know the
regime that murdered him seem like nice
people
seem like good guys we got a good
relationship if you were doing that for
some effect at least you could point to
the effect if you're doing it to no
effect then you just look like a tool
but President Trump says that this
wasn't a walk away
like you get up and walk out he said no
this was very friendly we shook hands
there's a warmth we have and I hope that
stays international negotiations are not
won or lost based on personal
relationships this is a myth of history
okay it wasn't that the Cold War ended
because not because President Trump but
because President Reagan and Mikhail
Gorbachev became friends the Cold War
ended because every incentive aligned
against Mikhail Gorbachev because
Gorbachev made the mistake of believing
that if he allowed a few of the fringe
nations around the edges of the Soviet
Union to leave then the others would not
leave and that he would be saving money
in the process this is well documented
inside the Soviet archives he didn't do
it because he was personal friends with
Reagan he was like you know what
communism is bad now I guess we're done
Gorbachev never expected the Soviet
Union's collapse negotiations do not
take place simply out of love between
the participants this is true in
business it's true in life it is
certainly turned international politics
where you are representing an entire
nation and or a dictatorship that has to
be preserved at all costs including the
cost of murdering many of its own
citizens there's no excuse for the
president's behavior here none none the
only excuse would have been if he had
somehow done all this crap and for some
odd reason that had worked and kim-jong
looted committed to denuclearization
with verifiability he committed to none
of those things and he still got out of
the president that they are besties and
also otto warmbier maybe you know maybe
it was just sort of an accident in one
of those crazy prison camps
so apparently Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo
he said that officials had worked
through the previous night and into the
morning to come up with terms acceptable
to both leaders he said when you are
dealing with a country that is of the
nature of North Korea is often the case
that only the most senior leaders have
the capacity to make those important
decisions he said we'll each need to
regroup a little bit there was no
statement from the Kim regime so giant
moral fail giant moral fail now maybe
this all results in something go down
the line but at this very moment if I
have to judge at this very moment and I
will judge the president on moral
grounds here no excuse no excuse for
that there's no I do not have the
capacity to speak in defense of a
president who is saying that otto
warmbier was what should that the family
about a warm beer should apparently be
trusted less than kim jeong-hoon
like i just don't know how to even
remotely justify that or explain it it
just it doesn't
in a second we're gonna get to the Cohen
hearings which as it turns out didn't do
a lot of damage to the president we'll
talk about that in just a second first
when men and women upgrade from their
shabby outdated multipack underwear to
Tommy John the most comfortable
underwear on the planet they have a lot
to say about it I do it graces my took
us at this very moment and it is
insanely comfortable men and women all
across America are crazy about Tommy
John both Tommy John's men's and women's
underwear sport and no wedgie guarantee
comfortable stay put waist bands and a
range of fabrics that are luxuriously
soft designed to move with you not
against you Plus Tommy John has dress
shirts and undershirts that always stay
tucked ridiculously soft loungewear and
go anywhere apparel that's versatile
enough to go from boardroom to boxing
class and for ladies check out their new
Tommy John air collection Tommy John is
so sure you're gonna love the fit and
feel it's all backed by their best pair
you'll ever wear or it's free guarantee
that means if you don't love your first
pair you'll get a full refund Tommy John
no adjustment needed hurry over to Tommy
John comm / Ben right now and get 20%
off your first order that is Tommy John
comm / Ben for 20% off Tommy John comm /
Ben go check them out right now all of
their goods are incredibly comfortable I
wear Tommy John underwear it myself so I
can vouch for them Tommy John comm / Ben
right now for 20% off and again they
have the best pair you'll ever wear
where it's free guarantee so you really
have nothing to lose go check them out
right now ok so the other big story of
the day of course is the fallout from
Michael Cohen's testimony Michael Cohen
was the president's personal fixer and
Cohen's testimony all you can really say
about it is that it gave pretty much
everybody what they want for the
Republicans it gave them good case that
the president did not actually involve
himself in illegal activity that the the
Trump Russia collusion stuff there's no
evidence to it and that the Trump
campaign finance stuff there's no
evidence to that either so on a legal
side Republicans win on an image making
side probably Democrats win so everybody
goes home happy except for Michael Cohen
who goes to jail sad I assume so the the
legal side Cohen's had a bunch of things
that actually cut in favor of President
Trump so let's begin with the argument
that president from colluded with the
Russians in 2016 and with WikiLeaks so
Cohen says that Trump talks with Roger
stone about WikiLeaks now the problem
for Trump is what he said - what he said
to the Muller investigation so he has
written testimony if he was asked
specifically
about whether he talked to Roger Stone
about WikiLeaks then presumably this
could maybe be a problem then it's
Michael Cohen saying that he did talk to
Roger stone Trump saying he didn't talk
to Roger stone but here's the point if
you put aside the the answers he gave to
Muller
if Trump talked to Roger stone about
WikiLeaks in the way that Michael Cohen
says he did there is no collusion and no
violation of law here's what Cohen said
based on your experience with the
president and knowledge of his
relationship with mr. stone do you have
reason to believe that the president
explicitly or implicitly authorized mr.
stone to make contact with WikiLeaks and
to indicate the campaign's interest in
the strategic release of these illegally
hacked materials I'm not aware of that
was mr. stone a free agent reporting
back to the president what he had done
or was he an agent of the campaign
acting on behalf of the President and
with his apparent authority no he was a
free agent he frequently reached out to
mr. Trump and mr. Trump was very happy
to take his calls okay so he was a free
agent not working for Trump and Trump
took his calls and then when stone told
him that WikiLeaks was gonna release
stuff on Hillary
Trump was like oh great okay that's not
collusion that's Trump being informed of
a fact
and then Trump saying good that is not
Trump colluding that is not him actively
participating that's not legal liability
other evidence that there's no legal
liability when it comes to the collusion
stuff Michael Cohen who's as close to
the president as anybody according to
his own testimony he was asked do you
have any evidence that the president
colluded with Russia and Cohen says no
not at all actually the questions have
been raised about whether I know of
direct evidence that mr. Trump or his
campaign colluded with Russia I do not
and I want to be clear but I have my
suspicions okay so he has his suspicions
but who cares about Michael Cohen
suspicions I mean the guy's a legitimate
fraudster who's going to jail for a taxi
medallion scheme for perjury who cares
about his suspicions he doesn't have any
evidence that's all that matters then he
was asked have you been to Prague so
this is only important because the steel
dossier which has been the linchpin of
the argument that President Trump was
colluding with the Russians had a claim
that Michael Cohen had traveled to
Prague to negotiate with the Russians on
behalf of campaign Trump he's asked
specifically about did he ever visit
Prague
says nope never been there have you ever
been to Prague I've never been to Prague
never have I've never been to the Czech
Republic
okay so in order Cohen has now debunked
the idea that Trump was colluding with
WikiLeaks that collusion generally was
happening and that he personally was
involved in anything the sealed dossier
talked about demonstrating once again
that the steal dossier was basically
just a mash-up of garbage that
Christopher Steele was trying to dump
onto the Hillary Clinton campaign via
perkins coie and that that was
eventually moved to it's a fusion GPS
right that that's that's Cohen to
bunking half of these Democratic talking
points for the last three years and then
it gets worse
because Michael Cohen talks about the
the payoff deal that Trump had with
stormy Daniels now his suggestion is
that he paid off stormy Daniels at
Trump's direction as I mentioned
yesterday there are two elements
required in order for Trump to violated
campaign finance law one the payments of
stormy Daniels must have been seen as a
campaign contribution meaning that if
Trump had a long history of paying off
women to shut up that's not actually
evidence in favor of the campaign
finance violation it's evidence against
the idea that there was a campaign
finance violation a campaign expenditure
is an expenditure that takes place only
in the context of the campaign that's
why if I eat lunch on the campaign I
can't charge that to the campaign
because I'm gonna eat lunch normally if
however I'm flying to Iowa for the
campaign then I wouldn't be flying to
Iowa for one for the campaign that's
campaign expenditure well if I pay off
women on a regular basis then me paying
off this woman this time is probably
also not a campaign expenditure so that
was question number one is it a campaign
expenditure question number two did
Trump know that he was violating
campaign election law and trying to end
around disclosure requirements by using
Cohen as a cutout and the answer if
Cohen does this on a regular basis is no
because if he's been using Cohen as a
cutout for ten years what's the claim
that he did it specifically this time to
avoid law here's Cohen basically
admitting that there's no legal
liability even in the campaign finance
case catching kill is a method that
exists when you're working with a news
outlet in this specific case it was a mi
National Inquirer David Packard Dylan
Howard and others where they would
contact me or mr. Trump or someone and
state that there's
story that's percolating out there that
you may be interested in and then what
you do is you contact that individual
and you purchased the rights to that
story from them he's catching kill
scenarios existed between David pecker
and mr. Trump long before I started
working for him in 2007 okay so this has
been going on for years and years and
years and years therefore this is
probably not a campaign expenditure and
then he says yeah I was personally
involved in killing a couple of these
stories like for example there was a
story about a love child that turned out
to be nonsense I was involved in killing
that story there's a story about Trump
hitting Melania in an elevator that
didn't happen and I tried to track that
down it didn't happen either again none
of this cuts in favor of Democrats is
there a love child there is not to money
to the best of mine no you would pay off
someone to doesn't mean more it was am i
it was David pecker so he paid off
someone about a love child that doesn't
exist
correct who's about $15,000 okay so
again if there's a long history of
paying off people then this particular
payoff is not a campaign finance
violations now it doesn't mean it's not
embarrassing doesn't mean the president
doesn't do embarrassing stuff he does he
does embarrassing immoral stuff that
does not make it illegal immoral
embarrassing stuff is not grounds for
impeachment impeachment is about high
crimes and misdemeanors now in a second
we're gonna get to the only real attempt
to try and catch Trump in serious legal
violation and then we'll get to the
stuff that was bad for president Trump's
just in terms of the headlines in one
second first go over to daily wire and
subscribe for $9.99 a month you will
subscribe to daily wire that means that
you get the rest of this show live it
also means that you get two additional
hours of the show later today we have
great guests on we had on Ben Sasse two
days ago we had on the the House
Minority Leader yesterday we have great
guests on the show on a routine basis
not only that we bring you two hours of
additional live coverage of the news
later in the afternoon you can only see
that behind the paywall for 99 bucks a
year or $9.99 a month the $99 year is in
fact cheaper get the leftist here's how
to run called tumblr when you do all of
that as well we also have special access
to our Sundays special which is
available on Saturday we have special
questions that we ask our guests that
you only get if you are a subscriber if
you want to interact with me during my
radio show then you can ask me questions
during the breaks and I will answer them
so all sorts of good stuff happening
behind the paywall go check us out over
there
also make sure to subscribe over a
youtuber iTunes and leave us review we
always appreciate it we're the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
so the only real attempt to get Cowan to
implicate Trump in illegal activity in
any serious way was actually made by aoc
so Alexander Ocasio Cortez who for some
reason has been giving a plum spot on
the House Oversight Committee she
actually did a pretty good job of trying
to tie down Michael Cohen to a story
that could result in at least the
capacity for the Democrats to try and
grab from tax records she asked if Trump
tried to commit fraud and then Cohen
says yes and that provides the impetus
for Democrats to now try to subpoena
Trump's tax tax records so here's
Michael Cohen giving these answers
October 2018 the New York Times revealed
that quote President Trump participated
in dubious tax schemes during the 1990s
including instances of outright fraud
that greatly increased the fortune he
received from his parents he also helped
formulate a strategy to undervalue his
parents real estate holdings by hundreds
of millions of dollars on tax returns
sharply reducing his tax bill when those
properties were transferred to him and
his siblings mr. Cohen do you know
whether that specific report is accurate
I don't and would it help for the
committee to obtain federal and state
tax returns from the president and his
company to address that discrepancy I
believe so
okay so that is her basically just
saying that's what we're gonna do now
Cohen didn't give any basis for them to
actually subpoena the records cuz he
says he doesn't know but it she's going
to do that anyway so this is just the
beginning of the investigations not the
end meanwhile so on the legal side
Republicans can easily say Michael Cohen
provided no additional evidence of any
illegal activity that harms President
Trump on the bad headline side there's
gonna be a roundabout headlines because
whenever one of your members of your
inner circle turns on you and then talks
crap about you then and the mean you
don't like you that's gonna be a
headline so Michael Cohen you know
basically just badmouth the president
yesterday called them a racist you call
them a big ad call them a sexist and all
the rest but here's the problem even for
that like I really don't think that the
Cohen testimony hurts Trump in any
serious way after about a week and the
reason is because Cohen is innately not
believable and also dislikable so Cohen
is not only a convicted perjurer who's
going to go to jail Cohen also has an
unfortunate habit of seeing himself as
the hero
it's like that clip from the office with
Michael Scott talking about am I saying
I'm a hero yes I mean that's essentially
Michael Michael Cohen his closing
statement yesterday was so ridiculously
cringe-worthy here is Michael Cohen
explaining that he hoped that his truth
will help heal America first of all the
minute anybody says my truth you know
they're lying first of all I want to say
thank you all for being here today I am
humbled I am thankful to chairman
Cummings for giving me the opportunity
today to tell my truth and I hope that
as chairman Cummings said it helps in
order to heal America and I thank you
all again have a good day okay if
anybody truly thinks that this is
helping to heal America you got another
thing coming man I mean it's just
silliness and and the Democrats attempt
to paint michael cohen as some sort of
redeemed hero was similarly
cringe-worthy Elijah Cummings who's the
chairman of the House Oversight
Committee under the new Democratic
Congress he says listen we're better
than this we can be redeemed because
Michael Cohen can be redeemed Michael
Cohen he's changed his life here yeah if
anybody believes that I got a bridge in
Brooklyn to tell you you come saying I
had made my mistakes but now I want to
change my life we as a nation did not
give people an opportunity after they
made mistakes to change their lives a
whole lot of people would not do do very
well we are better than this we are so
much we really are as a country we are
so much better than this no we're not
hey sorry sorry breaks you we're not
that's why we're here right the reason
that we're here is because we're not
better than this the opposing candidate
in the last election cycle was Hillary
Clinton the most corrupt woman in the
history of modern American politics so
no we are not better than this the last
presidents of the United States was
involved in innumerable scandals the
only difference that the media didn't
care about those scandals we're not
better than this American politics has
been like this for a very long time it's
just that now the mask is off because
President Trump is very obvious and also
because the Democrats are very obvious
in the media are very obvious now that
the most the worst moment of the entire
day
actually had nothing to do with Michael
Kahn it had to do with Rasheeda Talib so
Rasheeda Talib is just a vile human
being she's a nasty nasty person and you
can tell she's a nasty person not just
because she's an open anti-semite but
also because the congresswoman from
Michigan does stuff like this so
yesterday mark Meadows brought in Lynn
Patton from the White House with whom he
has friends and he said and she's also
close with Trump to sort of rebut the
allegation that President Trump was a
racist now as I say I think this is dumb
I don't think it's racist I do not think
it is a racist thing to say you know
here's another black person who knows
the president she says he's not a racist
I think is a bad argument I think it's a
stupid argument because not everyone of
any race is going to have the same
opinion about any person so I think
there's a dumb argument so I think this
is racist of course not but here is Mark
Meadows doing it I guess what I'm saying
is is I've talked to the president over
300 times I've not heard one time a
racist comment out of out of his mouth
in private so how do you reconcile it do
you have proof of those conversations
but I would ask so why you asked me a
question so you have over here's you
have proof yes or no I do Oh where's the
proof yes miss Patton how many people
were black our executives at the Trump
Organization we can go through this I
would ask unanimous consent that her
entire statement be put in the record
okay so is that a silly gambit yes it's
a silly gambit but does it make Mark
meadows a racist the answer of course is
no but according to Rasheeda Talib it
does make him erases so in a second I'm
gonna play you Rasheeda Talib going
after Mark Meadows and suggesting he's a
racist this is so out of bounds that
even Elijah Cummings had to step in so
this does explain a difference right now
between the modern newfangled Democratic
Party and maybe some the older members
of the Democratic Party mark meadows and
Elijah Cummings are really good friends
they've been good friends for many many
years the new members of the Democratic
Party however have been deeply in
ensconced in the idea that every
Republican down deep is a vicious evil
racist so here's Rasheeda Talib calling
mark Meadows a racist for the crime of
having said here's a black friend of the
President of the United States who's not
a racist just to make a note mr.
chairman just because someone has a
person of color a black person working
for them does not mean they aren't
racist and it is in sense
the fact that someone would actually use
a prop a black woman in this chamber in
this committee is alone racist in itself
mr. chairman mr. mr. meadows wait a
minute I've defended you and falsettos
I'm there yes sir you like you I will
clear this up now mr. Lieb is it I want
to make sure I understand you did not
you were not intending to call mr.
meadows erases is that right
no mr. chairman I do not call mr.
meadows at racism I am trying as a
person of color mr. chairman just to
express myself and how I felt at that
moment I listened very carefully to Miss
Ellie and I think and I don't want if
I'm not gonna put words in her mouth but
I think she said that she was not
calling you a racist because there's
Cummings trying to quell that
controversy now the truth is that Talib
was of course calling Meadows a racist
because totally even in half the
Democratic Party are constantly calling
Republicans racist at the drop of a hat
this is why Republicans don't take
seriously accusations of racism in some
cases to their own detriment because
Democrats are willing to call everything
racist Cummings at least has the
wherewithal to say hey that's that's not
right I mean let's not go there but does
to leave actually believe that Meadows
is a racist sure because why not the New
Democratic Party believes that anyone
who doesn't agree with their agenda is
inherently an innately racist and
racially bigoted and it's it's pretty
gross good for Elijah Cummings for at
least stepping in and shutting that down
and in other news it is important to
note here that I mentioned yesterday
that Matt Gaetz who's the Republican
Congress person from Florida who
basically threatened Michael Cohen
before his testimony he has now tweeted
out I've personally apologized to
Michael Cohen referencing his private
family in the public square regardless
of disagreements family members should
be off-limits from attacks from
representatives senators and presidents
including myself
let's leave the Cohen family alone we
said that after Bar Association
initiated actual investigation into him
in the state of Florida many reports
today that gets was on the phone with
President Trump and Trump had basically
suggested that he do this thing with
Michael Cohen in the first place which
again is a is a thug tactic
and has no place in American politics I
mean it's just it's it's a mob is a mob
tactic all of this is extraordinarily
ugly what's the final impact of it
nothing I mean really because nothing
matters anymore
I think that's that's sort of the theme
is that that very few things matter if
we are a people of principle then a lot
of this should matter we should be able
to say that president Trump engaged in
immoral activity but that's not illegal
activity and illegal activity is
necessary for an impeachment on North
Korea we should be able to say the
president his his statements are immoral
immoral and you may agree with the
President on policy you may like the
president you may back the president but
immoral is immoral we should be able to
hold all of these thoughts
simultaneously
unfortunately because nothing matters
and everything is stupid people want to
get rid of their cognitive dissonance by
suggesting that there are good guys and
bad guys in American politics there are
very few good guys and there are a lot
of people who are mediocre and there are
a significant number of bad guys that's
the actual breakdown of good guys bad
guys and people in between in American
politics okay meanwhile speaking of
corruption is not restricted to the
United States and it would be silly to
suggest that America is more corrupt in
more dirty and then any of the other
nations of the West what people have not
paid attention to this but Justin
Trudeau in Canada is in serious trouble
handsome Bernie up north that guy's got
some real problems
according to Bloomberg Justin Trudeau is
facing the most explosive crisis of his
administration after his former attorney
general detailed a month-long campaign
by the Canadian prime minister's office
to quietly end a legal problem for an
iconic Quebec construction firm in
dramatic testimony that lasted nearly
four hours Jodie Wilson Raybould broke
her silence with a detailed account of
efforts by Trudeau and top aides to
persuade her to step in and end
prosecution of SNC lavell in Group Inc
she argues it amounted to interference
in the judicial system she concedes it
wasn't illegal Trudeau says he was
trying to prevent job losses in his home
province of Quebec by interfering in the
judicial system the former attorney
general says I experienced a consistent
sustained effort by many people within
the government to seek to politically
interfere Wilson reybold's who quit the
cabinet this month also said she faced
veiled threats about what might happen
if she refused to order an out-of-court
settlement
her testimony shook the core of Justin
Trudeau's team naming him his finance
chief and his most senior aides
conservative leaders have been trying to
uncie Trudeau and they're calling for
his resignation in the poll suddenly the
Conservative Party is surging in Canada
thanks to all of this that's not the
only corruption that is being charged
there's corruption charges now issued
against Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu the Attorney General of the
State of Israel announced on Thursday
his office had indicted Netenyahu on
corruption charges after a two-year
investigation there apparently one count
of bribery and two counts of fraud and
breach of trust
the most serious allegation against Bibi
involves his relationship with shallow
elevate the controlling shareholder of
an Israeli an Israeli telecom company
called Bozek Bezeq police recommended an
indictment in the case based on evidence
collected that confidence of Netanyahu
promoted regulatory changes worth
hundreds of millions of dollars to Bezeq
in exchange they believe Netanyahu used
his connections with elevant to receive
positive press coverage on Bezeq spa
peeler subsidiary news sites Wallis the
ideas that he traded favors for positive
news coverage police have said that
their investigation concluded that
Netanyahu and Elevation gauged in a
bribe based relationship that is the
most serious charge the other charges
against him are a lot less serious the
conclusions are published 39 days prior
to a general election so people have no
idea how this is going to impact the
vote Bibi is actually his Likud Party is
running second to a unity party created
by the sort of center right and center
left in Israel with the indictment
coming down
there's great uncertainty as to what
happens in Israel max so when we talk
about corruption in the United States
recognize that corruption in government
is sort of endemic to government the
good news is that in Western democracies
people try to do something about it as
opposed to in North Korea where you just
kill everyone who asks a question
alrighty so time for some things I like
and then some things that I hate all
right
things I like you have to love Chuck
Schumer Chuck Schumer is the Senate
Minority Leader and he's stuck between a
rock and a hard place why because the
base of his party is extraordinarily
extreme and the mainstream of his party
knows that if the base takes control
they have a real problem on their hands
so he's got the base of his party
clamoring for a vote on this green New
Deal the green New Deal resolution is a
bag of crap it's just a horse manure or
cow manure or cow farts whatever you
please it's just a terrible proposal it
contains all sorts of nonsensical
resolutions about solving climate change
in
years it puts all these pie-in-the-sky
proposals out there
nothing policy-oriented and Mitch
McConnell the Senate Majority Leader
said you know what let's vote on this
thing let's get Democrats on record are
they really willing to embrace this sort
of nonsense here is Chuck Schumer gamely
trying to say that it is Republicans
fault that a bill the Democrats proposed
could make it to the floor for a vote
McConnell knocking the green new deal I
would ask the leader and we're going to
keep asking him and every Republican in
this chamber what they would do about
climate change about global warming
until leader McConnell and his
Republican majority answer those
questions the games they're playing here
will have no meaning this is not a
debate it's a diversion it's a sham okay
so what it's a diversion than a sham to
bring up your proposal for a vote I
demand a vote it's super important okay
here's your vote this is a sham why are
you telling me to vote pick one pick one
guys so that so that's really funny so
well done Senate Majority Leader
McConnell for allowing Democrats to
humiliate themselves this one definitely
falls under the old aphorism that you
give people enough rope to hang
themselves and that's basically what the
Democratic Party is doing right now okay
time for a couple of things that I hate
okay thing that I hate number one so
Senator Ed Markey I love this too
Senator Ed Markey this ties right in he
is one of the co-sponsors of the green
New Deal he's talking about he says
listen young people know it's time for a
revolution a revolution in this country
here's senator Markey they think that
the green New Deal is just the Revel a
resolution but it's a revolution it's a
revolution young people want a green
energy revolution in our country they
know we can do this they know that all
of these new technologies can be
invented these new technologies can be
deployed oh my goodness okay so sorry we
can stop them there I look young people
know that we can invent stuff that
nobody knows what the hell they're
talking
talking about young people know that we
can manufacture diamonds from horse crap
young people know that if we just wish
hard enough then money will pour from
the skies like gods mana that's what
that's what young people know I also
love it when senators do this this
wordplay it's always really awkward like
this resolution isn't a resolution it's
a revolution you see what I did right
there just switch the S for the V you
see that ya clever huh resolution
revolution revolution just keep
switching the letter out pretty great ed
markey does this I love that he's like
young people know how vital this is and
then McConnell's like vote on it like no
stop that
no no because the revolution will not
require you to vote apparently it'll
just require you to say silly things
okay other things that I hate today so
this one if you're eating breakfast now
is not the time to do so if you are a
subscriber and you can see this there is
a woman who has now smeared herself with
menstrual blood saying that you wanted
to show that periods are both beautiful
and powerful first of all super
transphobic what about women who don't
have periods and what about men who do
have periods has anyone thought of those
people second of all this this look look
we worked way better in Braveheart
worked way better in Braveheart also I
don't think that those words mean what
she thinks they mean beautiful and
powerful now I'm just gonna put this out
there bodily fluids not the best just no
matter from which orifice bodily fluids
smearing them on yourself not great not
great Bob so not sure why exactly this
is why somebody would do this unless
they're a crazy person well this person
is a crazy person her name is it Dimitra
nix 26 although I don't want to assume
her sex because obviously we can't do
that anymore she's a sex coach so I get
maybe that's what maybe that's what this
is maybe this was like it maybe there's
a Braveheart motivational tactic she's a
sex coach so she smears herself with
menstrual blood that she's like do it do
it now own it so she is she's trying to
end the stigma and shame around periods
all she is succeeding in doing is having
people back away slowly into the bushes
like Homer Simpson she says that she
regularly posts these photos to her
Instagram
Paige she lives in LA California because
my city is intensely stupid she had her
first period aged 12 just like most
young women I know shocking but was
ashamed of it and thought it was
disgusting she would try and hide her
period from boyfriends worried about
bleeding through her clothes well first
of all shouldn't we all be worried about
bleeding through our clothes from
wherever like that's that's not sanitary
as a general rule she said I was
simultaneously embarrassed and
fascinated by my period I felt
apologetic about it a lot and tried to
hide it from boyfriends our society
teaches us that periods are dirty and
inconvenient well they're not clean and
convenient from what I hear from women
and you know I've never heard a woman
who is like you know what my period came
it was so clean and so convenient for me
it's just great ads about menstrual
products talk about smelling fresh or
making us cleaner implying that our
body's natural functions are gross if
she doesn't think our body's natural
functions our grocery should smear poop
on herself and walk around I really when
my son doesn't want his diaper change
you know what I say to him it's time to
change your diaper because you have
gross poo poo I know deep thoughts here
on a Thursday but we have reduced adults
to dumber than our smallest children
either there very few parents who have
never had the experience of walking in
to a room and seeing your child with
their diaper around their ankles looking
at their own poop and you've thought
well that's a dumb thing because kids
are dumb when you're in your mid-20s and
you're still doing this with the stuff
coming out of your body let me suggest
that you may have a problem larger than
the societal feelings about periods
unbelievable
and again supremely transphobic really
really transphobic and terrible a very
cisgender already I have to stop there
because I need to go vomit so I will be
back a little bit later if you subscribe
then you'll get two additional hours of
the Ben Shapiro show so check us out
over there or we'll see you here
tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Adam SIA vets
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Joshua alvera production
assistant Nick Sheehan the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19